et en direct dans ce gîte et tiphaine
walton porte parole du programme
alimentaire mondial en france
bonjour actifs et noir et lé ton merci
de répondre à nos questions en direct
sur arte france quelles sont les
prévisions du pam concernant l'impact de
la pandémie sur la faim dans le monde
effectivement comme votre sujet vient de
le souligner on est très inquiet parce
qu'on avait déjà 135 millions de
personnes l'année dernière qui était au
bord de la famine dans des conditions
vraiment difficiles
hélas les prévisions qu'on a sont assez
noir malheureusement est ce qu'on a on
estime que d'ici la fin 2020 il est
possible que 130 millions de personnes
supplémentaires face enfin ça se passe à
des conditions encore plus difficiles
liées à différents problèmes déjà
existants les conflits les problèmes de
sécheresse les premiers à un changement
climatique
mais là également le coc u19 qui se
rajoutent parmi toutes ces difficultés
existantes pourraient entraîner encore
plus de personnes dans une situation
alimentaire très critique alors quelles
sont les populations et les régions les
plus menacées par cette famine alors la
région qui nous inquiète le plus grand
du célé afrique puisque c'est là où il
ya le plus de population qui sont déjà
dans des situations critiques et
notamment aussi des économies qui sont
assez faibles dans le sens où elles sont
assez fragiles elles peuvent
malheureusement être encore plus touchés
par les ruptures de chaîne
d'approvisionnement on commence à
constater déjà avec des problèmes de
fermeture de frontières
le prix du baril qui s'effondrent
également certaines économies qui sont
très dépendantes de leurs exportations
ou de leurs importations en céréales qui
risque d'être très très impactées par
cette crise et il faut pas aussi oublier
certains pays au moyen-orient
ils sont aussi victimes de conflit
terrible depuis des années qui ont
entraîné beaucoup de gens au bord du
gouffre au bord de la crise alimentaire
en somalie par exemple on pense au yémen
par exemple
effectivement le domaine qui est une des
grandes opérations du programme aliments
un mondial qu'est ce que vous préconisez
alors pour éviter qu'ils et la famine
dans le monde quelles sont les solutions
alors il ya plusieurs éléments d'une
part le programme alimentaire se
mobilisent pour faire face à ses
problèmes de chaîne d'approvisionnement
au problème de blocage de frontières au
fait qu si les vols commerciaux pour
beaucoup ne fonctionnant plus et puis
difficile pour les personnels
humanitaires le personnel médical de se
déplacer et d'aller sur le terrain est
il plus difficile de bouger aussi du
matériel ou des vivres donc de ce point
de vue là nous nous sommes l'épiné
dorsale en fait de la logistique
humanitaire dans le monde donc on se
mobilise on a fait un appel de 350
millions de dollars pour pouvoir
renforcer notre chaîne logistique mettre
en place de nouveaux hubs au pouvoir
permettre la distribution rapide et le
prépositionnement aussi de stock et
aussi pour servir l'ensemble de la
communauté humanitaire donc les autres
les ong les autres agences des nations
unies pour qu'on puisse déplacer plus
facilement les personnels humanitaires
personnels de santé et matériels aussi
de santé donc ça c'est des choses qui
sont déjà en cours
par ailleurs ce qui est très important
pour nous c'est que le programme
alimentaire mondial certes plus de 100
millions de personnes dans le monde et
qu'on estime que 30 millions de ces
personnes si elles ne reçoivent plus
laides risquent de mourir de faim donc
il est essentiel pour nous de demander à
nos bailleurs de fonds d'accélérer les
financements qui était prévu pour début
2009 un don ca ressort à peu près 1,9
milliard de dollars pour pouvoir
prépositionné d'ores et déjà des stocks
de trois mois près des pays dont on
considère qu'ils sont intitulé man un
risque et pour éviter on est une rupture
de cette chaîne d'approvisionnement qui
pourrait précipiter des millions de
personnes vers la famille notre
directeur explique qu elle a dit au
conseil de sécurité qui ont
malheureusement on n'a pas les moyens de
poursuivre nos opérations et de
poursuivre nos opérations logistiques
égal bon on risque d'avoir trois cent
mille personnes par jour et pourrait
m'ouvrir de la faim dans l'étroit au
charmant mais comment faire cela vous
vous parler d'ajustement de cette
logistique qui semble assez lourde
annette et
la moitié de la planète voire les deux
tiers de la planète sont confinés la
distribution alimentaire implique
forcément également des rassemblements
importants de personnes
comment est ce que vous allez faire
justement pour éviter que le virus ne se
propage pour en même temps gérer et la
crise sanitaire et gérer la crise
alimentaire oui bien entendu mais c'est
une excellente question il faut pas que
l'on rajoute encore plus du risque pour
des personnes qui doivent se rassembler
sur des points de distribution mais est
souvent beaucoup donc ce qu'on fait
c'est qu'on a mis en place dès bien
entendu des règles de distanciation
sociale des stations de lavage de mains
on a multiplié les points de
distribution pour qu ils moins deux
personnes et la fréquence des
distributions aussi en dame quand on le
peut plus de rations plus de vivre
personne pour qu'elle n'ait pas à
revenir immédiatement chercher le mois
suivant ont tout ça c'est une expérience
qu'on avait déjà assez solide puisqu'on
était aussi en première ligne avec les
autres agences l' oms et les ong lors de
la crise des mollahs hilary celle que m
merci stéphane walton d'avoir répondu à
nos questions je rappelle que vous êtes
la porte parole du pam en france le
programme alimentaire mondial